it was so excited Game of Thrones Season
4 is coming Caray I know I can't wait I
mean I kind of watched a show on two
levels obviously as an actress in it and
because I'm a huge fan of it so I get so
excited about that so what has it been
like being on Team Targaryen it's been
very cool I have to say you know how
many people get to work with Dragons you
know
yeah I've absolutely loved every second
and do you think Danny's got what it
takes to lead you to victory and how
important you think for Sunday might be
in that Danny can totally be queen
absolutely I mean she's not just
ferocious and you know focus on what she
wants to do and she'll do what she has
to do to get where she needs to go she's
actually coming from a really good place
and you know her morals and she wants to
save everyone and I feel like she she's
got everything that you would want in a
leader you know so and someday hopefully
can guide her in that in that quest
hopefully now what's it like working on
set with Emilia Clarke I've heard that
Beyonce songs been a little bit apart in
your scene
well yeah I mean it's all about who runs
the world girls obviously okay yeah
obviously we love Beyonce and we had a
lot of fun on set singing her songs and
just applying Beyonce songs to scenes
and you know I mean it's a lot of fun
she's a really funny
sweet girl so we we had a great time
working school I was a bit like joining
as a new girl on the block as it were
and do you think you've got what it
takes to stay alive in Game of Thrones
well I would like to hate say who knows
who knows but and it was very
nerve-racking for me coming onto the
show because I was such a huge fan of it
but then everyone was so lovely and just
introduced me for everyone and everyone
was just like lovely and I didn't feel
like the new girl anymore and it was
really easy and I didn't it was it was
amazing how easily I fits in and just
because it's not just cast through
everyone involved are just the nicest
group of people
we're lucky really lucky it makes such a
difference it makes a huge difference I
mean actually I've not really works with
anyone I've not like ever do thing so
you know it but it does everything goes
so much smoother like the kind of
vastness of the scenes that like the
size of the scenes and the extras and
all that production it has to it has
that we wouldn't work if we didn't have
such a great team so yeah I was a fan
and an actress in the show what have
been your favorite game of Thrones
moment so far and who to think had the
best death
who's at the best dead
that is a hard one this is not so many
for me I think the most shocking one was
Ned Stark's you know because I I wasn't
expecting it because at that time I
hadn't liked what the books or anything
so I didn't know and it was for me the
most shocking so that one probably be my
most like my favorite death in this in
the show
your favorite moment in the show me it's
been this season and I may be a little
bit biased because I haven't been seen
but it was the moment where we finds out
Daenerys spoke malaria and she just I
think everyone's respects with a
character just wearing a bra Megan
there's you know who just went through
the roof and she it was such a fantastic
scene I was like really even though I
knew it was going to happen just seeing
it all together was a brilliancy now as
I say we're so glad it's got for season
how could it ever a bit in question it's
truly not what would you like to see
happen next season on the show well I
don't know I mean I just think that
we're going to get to the gritty bits
now we're getting to the lightens of the
day starting to the battle it's going to
be a lot of pack sure and you know just
more excitement anymore
like I'm holding on wait and see what
happens and that's suspense and I think
that's just going to continue and
respond so stick really now if you have
my son die on the show who would you
like to be and I've got questions
through if you only send a on the show
who would you like to be any character
I'd like to place a say because she's
loved playing evil characters I think
they're really fun and obviously she's a
figure of beauty and grace and she gets
to wear those fabulous gowns and that
wig are amazing my hair only does this
so you know the thought of wearing a
lovely long blonde wig makes me feel
really happy and yeah I think I'd really
like to play her because I think she
would be free fun like you know
it should be really fun to play cause
she's so evil now what do you think
about Joffrey's well he's super even if
you think Circe's bad he's all yeah
Joffrey he's pretty mean as me I mean
I'm not sure if he's as mean as this one
here yeah you and Riaan the new boy on
the show he's hopeful I mean it's funny
cuz he's look like the loveliest guy
ever so it just shows how great he is at
playing them
yeah Joffrey he's a bad egg that one not
happy with him I mean I met at mm very
briefly yeah and he was so sweet so you
know again when these lovely boy is
playing these horrible people
how'd you two get rid of Joffrey in any
way cause he'd like to see Daenerys on
the throne how would you do it because
he's so against the EM
the talk area thus far that he thinks is
his father
I feel like he should get you little
bird back racket not so I think
kind of like just
what would you like to say to fans are
watching it interview I was dyslexic
watching flexible then lovely support
that I've been given and welcome to the
show I've really enjoyed every second so
keep watching it's going to be very
exciting
you